WEREN'T EVEN WILLING TO SPEND
THE MONEY WE WERE GIVING THEM.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, TREY GOWDY,
YOU KIND OF IMPRESSED ME A
LITTLE BIT.
A GUY THAT USED TO BE A
PROSECUTOR.
I WATCHED YOU, YOU HAVE HAD A
LOT OF GOOD MOMENTS WHEN YOU
DRILL DOWN INTO SOMEBODY, AND
USUALLY GETS PRETTY HOT FOR THAT
PERSON, BECAUSE YOU BASE THINGS
ON FACTS.
I WANT TO ASK YOU, ONE OF THE
MAIN QUESTIONS YOU THINK ARE
UNANSWERED BY ROBERT MUELLER?
I WATCHED YOU ON BENGHAZI AND
OTHER MOMENTS, YOU ARE A
PROSECUTOR THAT HAS NEVER LOST A
CASE.
WHAT WOULD YOU ASK HIM, WHAT
NEEDS TO BE ANSWERED?
>> WELL, SEAN, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HAVING ME ON.
I WANT TO THINK IN TERMS OF
BUCKETS.
I FRANKLY WOULD START, KEEP IN
MIND, DEVIN AND JIMMY AND
RADCLIFFE ONLY HAVE 5 MINUTES,
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY STRATEGIC
WITH A NARROW GOAL APPEARED
START WITH BIAS.
YOU GOT RID OF PETER STRZOK
BECAUSE HE WANTED CLINT INTO WIN
AND TRUMP TO LOSE, YET HE HIRED
PEOPLE WHO WANTED CLINTON TO WIN
AND TRUMP TO LOSE.
THE HOW MUCH BIAS ARE YOU
WILLING TO PUT UP WITH?
YOU FIRED STRZOK BUT HIRED A
BUNCH OF PROSECUTORS THAT FELT
THE SAME WAY.
NUMBER TWO, SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
ASK ABOUT THIS LEGAL ISSUE, IF
YOU CAN RESIST AN UNLAWFUL
ARREST.
CAN YOU RESIST AND ON PREDICATED
INVESTIGATION?
WHICH FORCES US TWO TO GO TO THE
ORIGINS OF THIS RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, AND HOW MUCH TIME
DID HE SPEND CYCLING THROUGH
THAT?
THEN I WOULD GO TO WHAT DID YOU
FIND?
NO COLLUSION, NO CRIMINAL
COLLUSION, DESPITE TWO YEARS.
WHAT DID YOU NOT FIND?
AN INDICTABLE OFFENSE FOR
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
AND THIS IS A CATEGORY -- I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU DEVIN AND
JIMMY TO THINK ABOUT THIS --
WHAT DID YOU NOT BOTHER TO LOOK
FOR?
JUST GOT THROUGH TALKING ABOUT
SOMETHING ON THE POWER AND OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT THAT MAY HAVE
WANTED TO INFLUENCE EITHER AN
ELECTION OR THE ADMINISTRATION.
WE SPENT TWO YEARS FOCUSED ON
WHETHER A FOREIGN COUNTRY WAS
GOING TO INFLUENCE OR INTERFERE
WITH OUR ELECTION.
MUELLER, DID YOU LOOK AT OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT?
DID YOU LOOK AT WHAT OUR OWN
PEOPLE WERE DOING TO MAYBE PUT
THEIR FINGER ON THE SCALE?
DID YOU INTERVIEW
CHRISTOPHER STEELE?
DO YOU KNOW WHICH RUSSIANS WERE
FEEDING DIRT TO THE AMERICAN
ELECTORATE VIA THE DNC?
DO YOU INTERVIEW GLENN SIMPSON?
DID YOU INTERVIEW JIM COMEY
ABOUT WHY HE LEAKED THOSE MEMOS?